this video is sponsored by story box so
when it comes to lasers you ever think
we'll be able to make them so that we
can shoot them out of our eyes John you
see too many movies
just get real how's this for real
[Music]
we've all heard about lasers whyn't
which we know the word that you know
it's an acronym
yes yeah I didn't know that I mean here
it hey how do you sir
la ser okay light amplification by
stimulated emission of radiation bada
bing there you go
or stimulation of radiation that's sexy
lasers okay maybe we go back to 1917
okay Albert Einstein look just ignore
honey Albert Einstein little deep most
people know that he basically introduced
the physics concept of a laser whoa wait
a minute
are you for real yes and and and he
should have got a Nobel Prize but he
should have gotten like eight Nobel
Prizes exactly he got one but he
should've got an eight Lisa Greg hey so
one of them was writing down the
equation that allows us to even know and
understand that a laser can exist Wow
okay wait a minute so there were no
lasers and then he mathematically said
yo check out this laser no no he wrote a
research paper establishing the
principle of the laser the laser would
take another forty three years before it
got invented
that's how ahead of the time he was okay
oh my god right so the way it works is
you have an atom and it has electrons
way and the electrons if you excite the
atom can have an electron bump up to a
higher level okay think about energy
think it's like rungs of a ladder or
floors of an elevator in a building
right electrons can hang out if you find
that a higher life okay looks like
deuces I'm going out there you go so now
there it is now the electron doesn't
stay there it wants to the the whole
system wants to be a site and depending
on the energy level depending on the
atom depending on the conditions the
electron can stay there a short amount
of time or slightly longer before D
excites okay just basic electron
transitions and out there you go basic
it gets excited and then it comes down
it calms down right correct
okay and it does that all by itself oh
nice okay so now watch
if you send light with exactly the
amount of energy to allow an electron to
go from here to there
it'll get absorbed
Lextran will go up okay then when the
electron deep sights it send back out
exactly that same proton like a club
that's reach capacity to one go on in to
people up exactly would it be the same
let's say this this would have the
photon with the same amount of energy
right coming up now it turns out that
the photon that excited this energy
level this is einstein's brilliance if
you bathe this set of atoms in those
photons those photons will not only
excite the atom okay
they will actively D excite the atom
okay just by being in the bath nice it's
a spooky fact that's kind of the reverse
of being in the bath with me I'm just
saying so so that's the spooky fact
that's the stimulated emission right so
there's the electron it's gonna be
excited self right on its own time I
don't I'm right but if you put it in a
bath of these photons it'll make it
happen faster right so it goes up and it
comes right back down but that's all
contrived by the bath of photon it'll
make it come back right right and by
coming down it emits another Photon
right so now some saying oh this is so
cool right right right right okay so you
create a cavity or a very special cavity
with two reflective sides okay so that
when if when the photon of light gets
created it can stay in there right and
go back and forth and get magnified by
this phenomenon right as long as this
medium has these kinds of atoms
that'll respond to that photon right so
you're exciting the atoms but you're
amplifying the excitement we just
created the whole acronym light
amplification by the stimulated emission
of the radiation that is amazing wait a
minute he figured this out without he
being able to test it
he had an understanding of light and
atoms and and photons and out came his
calculators a calculation Wow was a
calculation that that
would happen and it'll happen until 43
years later we didn't make a box to have
that happen till early 1960s Wow right
and so back then lasers were like
expensive and they were rare and come to
late 60s early 70s you know who had a
lot of laser Goldfinger Goldfinger he
had like um big diabolical yes a evil
evil man laser
exactly right the best villain line ever
but is that the one weird that James
Bond is strapped to a table yes the
lasers coming right right up right up
his new business you expect me to talk
know Mr Bond I expect you to die was
that the line that's worth a lot that's
a great line you scare me I've gotta get
out more so that's a big old laser okay
so now lasers are like impulse items at
Kmart right I mean they're not something
that you need like license to get or
find in a laboratory because they got
cheaper better and so now we have a
low-power household lasers I have very
high powers that are still used in
laboratories and things anyhow so I
never leave home without lasers I I do
know that so I've have an assortment of
them here so this is this is one uh this
I got people who dope up my lasers oh
really
up in the Bronx you don't have people to
do that no okay so this is particularly
bright just look at this is a dark shirt
okay so so this is bright enough to I'm
scared a little but I use this at night
because I'm a planetarium director this
beam will MIT will go 60 miles into the
sky yeah and I can point out stars and
constellations that is amazing it is of
course it's dangerous for airplanes and
well yeah it's a never do that I'm
pretty sure that's illegal like yeah no
I got I'm sure yeah you know people I
got no people so that's that one so a
red little a little known fact a red
laser and a green laser of equal power
mm-hmm
the green laser is brighter even though
they have the same power why because
your retina is 2 or 3 times
sensitive to green light than it is to
red light that's him so the same
brightness energy brightness the green
will look brighter
so my two lasers here at green because
I'm pointing out stars in the night sky
so I can use the same amount of energy
you'd have in your red laser but it'd be
that much more visible to everyone
assembled so lasers had originally
industrial applications right but still
like what are you gonna do with a beam
that is so clever people started say hey
we can do a skin peel so depending on
the frequency of light that the laser is
it can have different penetration depths
or of certain materials including your
skin right so you can actually figure
out exactly how many how many can go
down and then and then burn that off
burn that up because it's very high
intensity light right and so a lot of
energy focused in one place because of
this cavity that builds the light and
then the light comes out so so so
there's that but I keep wondering if
Einstein only knew that in 1917 this
brilliant concept would be used for
cosmetic skin right I don't think yeah I
make I'm just wondering right it's just
work so these are some of the
applications always and of course the
military well of course yeah you get a
pumped-up enough laser and you want on a
Star Wars you can go into orbit and aim
it at the sensitive circuitry of an
enemy or rogue satellite and people
think of war you want to blow stuff up
know just what it is right you take it
out just take it out so if there's some
part of the hardware that's more
sensitive than other parts you hit a
laser to it and melts it burns it fries
the circuit the the the semis dead in
the water at a couple more examples okay
also in medicine right so it turns out
the hemoglobin just blood cells right
are highly absorbent in green white so
if you have a very intense green laser
you can actually quarter eyes and open
wound
all right by this method right because
that's that's the blood cells that
you're trying to sort of stop right over
there go and you can just basically
you've seen the fuse if you're basically
yeah seems that right it's kind of
walled off walmart exact a big beautiful
and you can have very high intensity
lasers that are not just sort of killing
a cell or burning it but actually
vaporizing it so there's some lasers
that are powerful enough to vaporize
cancer cells if you've identified a
tumor or the like and so that gets us to
what else is there what was he using
lasers for how about when you look
inside to scan your food that they're
super buckos but becomes it's a barcode
right so barcodes are just lines of
different thickness right and actually
there are lines that representing a
series of numbers okay I could type in
those numbers if you want it and get the
same information that's in the barcode
right but the point is a laser doop
it's got it the price it's built into
the code and all of their boom that's
all there and you can get even more
information if you make it
two-dimensional because a barcode is
just one dimension right all right it's
all there's lines of different
thicknesses in one dimension you can
make a two-dimensional barcode which is
basically a QR code that's a little
squares with the Rorschach your the
laser tell me what you see laser so
it'll be cool if you have like a
three-dimensional storage of information
like a holographic so the the 3d version
of the QR Wow the QR is a 2d version of
the barcode right that'd be an
interesting way I'm more like boatloads
of information in a three dimensional
barcode I would I believe we call that
Neil deGrasse Tyson poster so Chuck we
done with laser yes as a matter of fact
I just like to take one of my laser okay
are my laser in that case maybe I'll
just take the time to tell you guys
about story blocks hey do you know the
key to making a professional-looking
video it's story blocks we even use it
here at start I didn't know that yeah as
a matter of fact you probably saw some
of their clips in this video okay yeah
so story blocks gives you studio quality
stock video without blowing up your
budget you get unlimited downloads of
anything in their video member library
including 4k footage After Effects
templates motion backgrounds and more
when you sign up for the unlimited video
plan I guarantee you it's much easier
and cheaper to find the video you need
on story blocks then it is to make it
yourself and really how you gonna get
that bitty
anyway suppose you need the perfect
aerial shot of the Statue of Liberty
what are you gonna do go ahead and get a
helicopter fly around the Statue of
Liberty until you get the perfect shot
find somebody that can edit that for you
fly over and restricted air you get what
I'm saying point you get it okay
check out the link in the description to
learn more about story blocks video that
story blocks dot-com slash star talk and
as always keep looking up
[Music]